the parents of New Jersey girl who took
her own life blamed school officials for
their daughter's death
Mallory Grossman was just 12 years old
her parents say they begged the school
for help but their pleas would never
take him seriously
they plan to sue over what they call the
school's failure to protect her from
bullying Don Dahler is outside Copeland
Middle School in Rockaway New Jersey
where Mallory was in the sixth grade Don
good morning good morning just hours
before her death Mallory Grossman's
parents say they spoke with
administrators here at the middle school
about the bullying they say their
concerns were ignored part of an alleged
pattern of negligence they believed led
to their daughter's suicide she was an
athlete and a cheerleader and gymnastics
and she's a sister she's a niece she's a
granddaughter she's the daughter Mallory
Grossman seemed vibrant and happy she
doesn't strike me as a typical candidate
for bullying we're all kind of really
surprised and not really sure how we got
here
Mallory's parents Diane and Seth
Grossman say the bullying started in the
fifth grade and she would come to me say
you know the girls were teasing me
calling me names sending me these
pictures on my time you know texting me
on my phone in January Mallory began
trying to avoid school she complained of
headaches and her grades suffered she
died a week before the start of summer
vacation
Bruce Nagel the Grossman's attorney
accused school officials of ignoring the
alleged bullying all the way up the line
nobody did anything here in June two
weeks after Mallory's death
Superintendent Greg McGann wrote to
parents our administrative team will be
meeting over the summer to review all of
our district procedures and plan for
district-wide community building at our
schools this will involve all of our
students staff and families I think
parents need to be you know aware of
what's going on I think that it's no
longer okay to say not my child
are you angry or you still just numb
there's a combination of both the
sadness over over takes everything
that's really a moment by moment the
Grossman's attorney says the lawsuit may
expand beyond the school in the district
to the parents of the girls who
allegedly bullied
malory the Morris County District
Attorney says this is an ongoing
investigation into her death the school
district did not reply to our requests
for comment Margaret such a sad story
Don thank you